Facebook is under fire again this
morning for how it handled evidence of
Russian election interference on its
site scathing New York Times report
based on interviews with more than 50
people shines a harsh light on
Facebook's two top executives it says
CEO Mark Zuckerberg and CEO of Sheryl
Sandberg ignored warning signs and then
sought to conceal them from public view
The Times report security experts at
Facebook flagged attempts by Russian
hackers to probe accounts as early as
spring 2016 that's months before
Zuckerberg downplayed the effect of
Russian propaganda on the 2016 election
it also said Sandberg oversaw an
aggressive campaign to combat Facebook's
critics in response to the article
Facebook told us we are working hard to
ensure that we protect our community
from bad actors CBS News contributor
Nicholas Thompson is Wired's
editor-in-chief and he joins us with
more on this expose Nick great to see
you a big bombshell from the New York
Times Facebook already responding by
saying that it's already ended its
relationship with that consulting firm
that was disparaging those who were
speaking out against Facebook is that
enough or do we need to see more of a
change specifically leadership well that
was a very small step they ended one
relationship with one company doing one
set of small things that a lot of people
were critical of so is that enough to
change it of course it's not enough to
change the narrative but the question
you're asked is exactly the right one is
there gonna have to be a big change in
leadership at Facebook my instinct is
probably not people still trust Sheryl
they still trust mark by by and large
they're very well respected by the board
which is the most important constituency
so I don't think they're going anywhere
so from a creditability standpoint where
does that leave facebook users Facebook
has a big credibility problem they've
had a growing credibility problem over
the last two years this story definitely
does not help the issue is is that in
2016 Mark Zuckerberg publicly said it's
crazy to think that they influence the
election or that there was Russian
involvement but the real story is that
inside Facebook they knew about Russian
involvement well okay so this is super
complicated to untangle so what he said
is that fake news didn't have a big
impact on the election at the time they
knew about some of the fake news and
they knew about Russian military
operations hacking Opera
the big question which isn't really
answered in The Times story is whether
they knew about the Russian propaganda
pages the fake pages and all those fake
ads if they knew about them then which
isn't what the time says then it would
say that they've been lying massively
the other question I don't think is
answered is related to Cambridge
analytical in the back door right that
Facebook allowed many of these whether
it was Russians or other advertising
companies access to personal security
information yeah so that is that is a
huge question and there's no question
Facebook didn't do it on purpose
remember Cambridge analytical was a big
disaster for the company the question is
whether Facebook knew about the problem
and should have done more previously
they basically said though very publicly
mark was on Capitol Hill it sort of had
a public flogging they've said listen
we've screwed up we made a mistake we
should have done more we should have
done better yeah what do you think needs
to happen now well okay so them to
really get out of this because the
question yeah biggest question for the
company and something that times has
been reporting on but it isn't in this
story is as the company fundamentally
changed do they take propaganda much
more seriously are they working much
harder to protect your privacy there's a
lot going on at the company right now I
think they're making steps we don't know
if they've done enough and for now you
think management is safe management is
safe Nick Thompson thank you so much you